well
[Music]
and say hello to héctor mejía with the
headlines for today thursday
december 17 a 3 year old boy dies
after a shot on wednesday
afternoon the police reported that this
happened last night in an
apartment complex near chorros streets
linear at this point in the
investigation it is not clear if the
shooting of the minor was an accident or
intentional so far no one has been
arrested at the scene the investigation is
continuing
it is expected that students may be able to
return to classrooms in the next few
months the district  cork county school
reached a tentative agreement with the
teachers union return to
school will be
phased students in grades K-
3 would be the first to
return
the plan will have to be reviewed by the district governing board before it is
approved  For now,
exact dates for the return are not determined and the
second coronavirus vaccine could be
approved this week while  so much
almost all the hospitals in the valley have
received shipments of vaccines including
the hospitals se rose the many can't
you ban yes and the hospital for veterans in
our veins
and even santa claus lined up to
receive the vaccine yesterday santa arrived at the
hospital  over the geox southwest of the
valley to get his shot in
preparation for his big night next week
and now let's look at the temperatures in the
extended forecast today Thursday
we will have a high of 62 degrees with
a low of 35 with a chance of
rain in some  parts of the valley for
the weekend temperatures
between 50 and 60 degrees are expected with clear skies,
Héctor Mejía informed you with
his brief news report on Kirchner in
Spanish
[Music]